bella a tutti sti che sono su questo
gioco cuore si chiama choice new game
ragazzino no non ho idea neanche di che
cosa sia però l'ho pagato 8 euro
sorprendere gli oggetti dai che costa 8
euro fammelo prendere un attrezzo va
bene allora niente attrezzi per 8 euro
però c'è un cerchio yes you can jump sì
ma non mi devi sbloccare una cimenta
anche se respiro va bene o c'è una porta
per nani questo è permetto per bizet
chiusa va bene a ciò il dj non l'avevo
mica visto ciao zio c'era una leva di
permesso che nove sono cagato addosso a
devo poi aprì la porta ma li mortacci
tua
va bene quindi vorrei un ray g game sta
roba ma io devo passare in mezzo
no oh mio dio cioè 9 rame ma che ci
stanno le lena scorsi visto gioco
maledizione va bene a me mi rifarei mica
a iniziare da capo ma c'è un punto di
salvataggio porca vacca bene chi è
responsabile chi è che mi ami salve quel
giorno tipo poverino lui mi fa un sacco
pena occhio che sicuramente succederà
qualcosa tipo veloce forse avrei dovuto
schiacciare attivate a chiatti attiva
tutto scherzavo scherzavo beh la mia
mira fantastica mi dico perfetta
all'inizio meraviglioso ok ai vai vai
vai vai sarà anche se sta servendo
questa roba prove
ma che 9
non riesco a fare un sacco ma un salto
che sia uno
ok vai vai vai vai vai veloce veloce più
veloce si guarda indietro lavorativi e
veloce porca vacca marta i due blu e
quello rosso ok ok come c'è sulla porta
in realtà quindi questo qua dovrebbe
aprirsi non si apre si sia per si apre
buon gesù all e ce l'ho fatta ci ho
messo meno di quanto ci ho messo nella
stanza principale però vabbè di qua e mi
fate salvare sì
la partita si salva la partita
queste scemi forte mi sa che non vengo
di qua però è stato bello provarci e
pietro è morto sha la la la la la
le pietre e vabbè allora o faccio un
salto olympic style non ci arrivò mai
9 st me la spieghi c'è qualcosa di
nascosto per forza va beh forse era
meglio l'altra parte quindi il ponte lo
devo tirare su a punto vedo e non ci
sono leve non è che ci sono leve
nascoste che non sto vedendo no perché
mi non mi potete più così e va bene raga
proviamoci perché
non vedo altra soluzione non ho capito
dove dovrei arrivare ma ok ok aiuto
salve mi devo tirare su un ponte io
perfetto questo ho aperto perfetto ea
senes trova che palle
ok allora vi ammazzo
fammi vedere cosa c'è
non mi fido non mi fido mai nella vita
quindi vado nell'altra mi fido mai di
nessuno figurazioni fido di un pozzo
senza fondo
tua sorella centrali dentro tua madre io
no perfetto allora vide morire la
famiglia proviamoci
secondo me uno dei due funzioni
all'altro no accumulo jolo se muoio vi
denuncio a tutti quelli che hanno fatto
il gioco allora c'è che l'ha fatto d'età
olimpic olympic dam
ok denunciamoli tutti tutti sti
maledetti non li conosco il re start era
un ora che non morì voce vi rendete
conto 3 salta come una puledra salta
salta un perfetto amiche ha levato
velocissimo stavolta bene rifacciamo
tutto quanto ami che posso rifarmi sto
gioco da capo ogni sacrosanta volta ossa
settimana ho giocato solare il game
impossibile porca vacca morta mackenna
magagna grazie alla grande niente da
capo ogni volta è tutto da capo ogni
volta porca vacca morta ogni volta lo
saltare qui un po di amor proprio per le
persone ma basta gesù ma non riesco più
a saltare prima cileno è sempre non
riesco più a salutare madonna se vi pare
non riesco più a saltare io lo so se
becca salta piano alone o non devi
saltare ingresso [ __ ] volta salta
bene salta bene
e ci voleva tanto mio dio che diavolo
ala perfetto se cambia anche quale dei
due è giusto non sa non è possibile non
posso andar 50 50 ogni volta quindi vai
a culo
vai nelle mani di gesù prova ci sembra
lo spike for quella di di happy with
game over
ma dai non posso rifarmi tutto ogni
volta c'è mica di perdo la ragione io
c'ho anche una fan ho più una vita e di
una vita maledizione una vita una
famiglia un cane o pietro devo badare a
pietro con l'amore se non ci sono io
muore perché non sono anche mangiare se
non lo invoco porca vacca e devo fare io
non posso sta qua di euro sta roba tutta
la vita la fioca le mani avanti le mani
schiocca le dita pietro è morto o tutta
la vita a ogni salto in teoria dovrebbe
essere questo volo giusto se le leve
sono messe così se no no no io ci provo
vai c'è se non è così raga non so
veramente come fare cioè mi arrendo
muoio me ne vado vado a fare il make up
artist morta tua sorella ragazzi spero
che questi 8 euro
se ricordato adesso quanto speso questa
roba spero che questo video vi sia
piaciuto spero che se siete noi ci
vediamo a un prossimo video ei prossimi
8 euro ben spesi e non vedo l'ora
me lo giuro beh ragazzi
[Musica]